yeah
good morning everyone if you all could
go ahead and take your seats I'd
appreciate it we're gonna get started on
day three of energy week it's been a
remarkable couple of days we're very
glad that you're here today and we're
very excited about the speakers that we
have so a couple of housekeeping items
for this morning as we start the day the
first is just a reminder to please
silence your cell phones tablets
anything that beeps we want to make sure
that we do that first um for questions
we are using an app called slide oh so
you don't I'm sorry I keep saying it's
an app you just download you just put it
into your browser slide Oh calm and then
you're able to put in a code and that
code is up on each of the slides that
have the presenter and you can insert
the questions that you have for that
particular for that particular speaker
we will be sending out a survey at the
end of our event and we're very
interested in your feedback so please do
answer that survey if you have specific
comments or questions you can also email
us directly it turns out that my email
is on it in a number of different places
so you can certainly find a way to reach
me in terms of thanks it's always good
to start the day with thank-you a
special thank you today to Amanda King
who has been running around behind the
scenes and making a lot of the magic
happen so I wanted to make sure that we
think
um in terms of sessions today we are
starting with Andrew place and I'm gonna
hold on talking about Andrew for a
minute because we have a special
introduction for Andrew at 10:30 our
English department is giving a
presentation or having a panel
discussion about the humanities and
energy for those of you who are here
yesterday you saw a dramatic monologue
competition we are very
cross-disciplinary here at Carnegie
Mellon and so this is a very good way
for us to sort of showcase that by
having some areas outside of the typical
ones that you would think about for
energy we will have lunch between 11:15
and 11:45 and then Chris White who is
the newly named CEO of philips Lighting
will be presenting at 11:45 so on the
agenda it has lunch and Chris together
because it is a lunchtime session Chris
will start promptly at 11:45 and I'll
remind you of that when we get closer at
12:30 we will have the the official
kickoff for the Allegheny clean tech
University prize collegiate competition
and at during that point we'll have one
minute pitches from each of the teams so
it's an exciting time to see those teams
and they have worked very hard to
prepare for this we have tours scheduled
between 1:30 and 3:30 we have a tour to
Hazelwood green which is the 178 acre
Brown field that's being redeveloped in
the a' city of pittsburgh we have a
walking hardhat tour of Tepper quad we
still have a few spaces available in
some of these so make sure that if
you're interested you show up at the
registration desk we have another that's
going to the hilltop urban farm again a
couple of spaces still available we want
to make sure that that bus is full and
there's a walking tour of Scott Hall
including the nanotechnology laboratory
we'll be talking about that specifically
the pitches and part of the competition
today are all being moderated by
Jeannette Armstrong who is the director
of the office of Technology transitions
for the US Department of Energy so she
will be
with us throughout the course of the day
as we have the competition the different
segments of the competition between 3:30
and 5:00 o'clock there's a student
poster competition and during breaks and
lunch you will actually see that many of
the posters are already set up there are
38 posters that are competing and so
many of you are actually serving as
judges for that so very excited about
all of that student work 38 posters is a
lot of posters for us to judge today at
5 o'clock we'll have our three finalists
from the day from the the cleantech
competition on stage to do ten minute
pitches and then we'll make those
announcements at 6 o'clock this evening
we actually are partnering with
sustainability weekend and we will have
a lecture from Balaji Ganapathy who is
with Tata Consultancy Services he's the
global HR and head of workforce and then
our final evening reception this evening
will be also in partnership with
sustainability weekend so this morning
I'm very glad to present our our speaker
as well as one of our best business
partners from the city of Pittsburgh
Alex pazzo Kennex
alex is a CMU alum he's also the
assistant director of mobility and
infrastructure for the city of
Pittsburgh
he studied in the Heinz College in
information systems and public policy
and he currently serves as the assistant
director of mobility and infrastructure
for the mayor for mayor William Peduto
in the city of Pittsburgh he's also a
board member of the Carnegie Lyme
Library of Homestead so Alex
thank you Anna
as Anna mentioned I am the assistant
director of the city of Pittsburgh's new
department of mobility and
infrastructure we have two charges in
our name brand new department as of a
year ago mobility and infrastructure how
we move about our city and how we
preserve those existing assets that we
already have and there's no five people
in Pennsylvania who have more of an
impact on the way that we do that in the
innovation that comes along with that
than the Pennsylvania Public Utilities
Commission there's a reason that the
Commissioner place and and the other
members of the Commission were the cover
models for the February issue of public
utilities fortnightly
which I swear to God is a real
publication I guess in this crowd you
probably are all subscribers to it 'men
Sylvania Utilities Commission both in
terms of helping to see the
transformation around traditional
utilities like electric and natural gas
but also in the regulation and the
balance between consumer and public
interests in new technologies that
didn't even exist two or three years ago
like 5g and ride-sharing which were
things that we are intimately involved
with in the department of mobility and
infrastructure as of this month the
Pennsylvania Utilities Commission is
embarking on new roles and
responsibilities with the Pittsburgh
Water and Sewer Authority here in the
city yet again serving that key role in
helping to balance the public interest
and the interest of the utilities so
commissioner places is the vice chairman
of the commission a beginning from his
appointment in October 1st 2015 was
nominated by Governor wolf he was
elected by his fellow commissioners to
be vice chairman also in 2015 prior to
his appointment and the Commission he
was the corporate director for energy
and environmental policy here in
Pittsburgh at eqt and previous to that
held a number of roles in the
Pennsylvania Department of Environmental
Protection including deputy secretary
for the office of energy policy energy
technology deployment he's a graduate of
the University of Pittsburgh as well as
a fellow alumnus of the Heinz College
here at Carnegie Mellon University
Commissioner place
[Applause]
thank you very much it's an absolute
pleasure of course to be here for many
reasons one it's great to see ed Rubin
and I teach a class now once a week I
come in on Mondays and it gives me an
excuse of nothing else to come back to
Pittsburgh can come back to Carnegie
Mellon which I have a huge respect for
and I think my son is going to come to
school here next year but that said I
think about I would did want to be
remiss if I didn't know the strength of
this University and the importance of
the graduates and the work that's coming
out of here in so many different
departments and I crossed paths with CMU
alums here there and everywhere locally
regionally nationally and globally and
the heft they bring to the issues that
the technical expertise the and it's
very true of my students I'm not sure
any air in the room at the moment but
the the half the intellectual capability
the dedication the diversity that comes
to through classes here and through the
graduates that I run into
I couldn't ask for just a more
fascinating place and that I
accidentally by moving to Pittsburgh 30
years ago I one or another find my way
to CMU and and remain connected in many
different ways
someone once said and I'm sure it's a
proverb that everyone knows it's a
cliche but what said about maybe we live
in interesting times
it's unfortunately and for better worse
very true and I think about the sort of
the path I've taken over the last
several weeks or months and days to get
here and I was in Mexico last week I was
in Harrisburg judicata in cases
yesterday I'm here today I'm in New
Jersey on Sunday for the
Horn ization of PGM States thinking
about demand response and D ER and all
the issues floating around at FERC and
PGM then on Tuesday I'm in DC testifying
at FERC on the Arkana
I've aggregation of how we aggregate
demand response storage thinking about
how all that's coming in over the next
year's and decades those really
challenging issues they're deep in the
weeds they're arcane they're not getting
never going to hit the front page of
anybody's paper but they really do
matter and in the broader context of
grid modernization the technology that's
coming in how we're financing it how how
we balance the obligations within the
commission of the utilities ensuring
that they remain viable and making the
investments that will put Pennsylvania
and great stead DS this year and the
years going out but also how we balance
that against the challenges of our
residents and ratepayers I wouldn't have
the governor's call to me was of a cold
called if I had served on the Commission
I never imagined that I would I was
perfectly content working in the
upstream oil and gas space there's still
a lot of work to do thinking about risk
think about mitigating risk but I a
friend of mine of Graduate School said
you know I may not be the smartest guy
on the planet but I'm smart enough to
know not to say no and I thought about
particularly again as I said bring it
back to that theme I mentioned about the
complexity and the importance of this
time we're in now and particularly in
Pennsylvania and sort of more regionally
to think about the PGM footprint there
is a huge amount of effort being put
into a grid modernization as I mentioned
how do we finance that how do we ensure
that we are investing in the right
places what does good monetization mean
we're pulling out pipe or put it we have
a disk accelerated recovery for pulling
out natural gas pipe well needed for
safety reasons
we have this aging infrastructure and
it's true across the Commission we
regulate everything from water
telecommunications wireline natural gas
electricity uber lyft taxis limousines
water dimension water across all of that
space we're dealing with this many of
the same track
and challenging issues that we have this
overlay or underlay of a system that was
built fifty hundred hundred years ago
twenty years ago for many cases of
populations that were larger than they
are today we're dealing with a
relatively static economy and we're
dealing with 1.3 million households I
think in the Commonwealth are living
within 1.5 times at the federal poverty
line so how do we deal with all those
issues that are often in in contrast or
in tension with one another those are
the things that drove me to go to the
Commission again if the Commission is
deep in the weeds it's never gonna
hopefully it doesn't hit the pages of
the paper but what the Commission does
how we regulate this how we do it well
or do it poorly balancing all those
needs does have substantive impact on
across the Commonwealth or economic
competitiveness and the suffering or
lack of suffering of residents the other
thing I was thinking about titling this
chattin was about all things FERC all
things PGM in many ways going to the
Commission on that all right I'm I'm
bounded in Pennsylvania this is what I
am this is my mandate this is what I'm
obligated to think about but
increasingly though all the water coming
over the transom all the the headwinds
and the issues we're dealing with so
many of them come back to issues that we
have a voice in at fur corn PJM first
and foremost thinking about well I can
sort of work back chronologically
but first energies emerged the
application to do e for essentially cost
recovery cost basis rate basing of
nuclear and coal generation I understand
where that comes from and I understand
the challenges they may face they're
facing it from renewables they're facing
it primarily from natural gas but how do
we we've bought into and we've accepted
and I think very rationally chosen to go
down competitive markets and if we are
we essentially we regulate natural gas
or coal and nuclear
about 70% of PJM generation mix that
will undoubtedly creator and competitive
markets and you might argue that that we
need to do that we need to rethink all
this but and I don't want a prejudge but
I will be following comments on this
case on this issue but I'm a firm
believer and the benefits of what
competitive markets have brought to us
and not negligent or oblivious to the
impacts on big generators like First
Energy re-regulating coal to natural gas
coal nuclear keeping us speaking would
be a substantive challenge I think it a
very difficult and deleterious impact on
the markets based but pulling back a
little bit more to the policy side of
that and I was at FERC the spring
arguing for a price on carbon I
understand the pain of the nuclear side
particularly the nuclear side we have 23
gigawatts of nuclear power in the
Commonwealth that's an important that
it's a fundamentally important zero
carbon resource if we were to if that
was to disappear on mass we were even in
part replacing that with renewables as a
multi-decade aleph and a astoundingly
expensive effort so I I understand the
challenges in nuclear I understand what
natural gas is been eating their lunch
but I'm gravely am greatly concerned
about the loss of nuclear power and the
particularly the Commonwealth but I am
also interested interested in
increasingly States and if you look to
the north more say to the north whether
it's New York or New England is oh we
have state policies and I think
perfectly valid state policies coming
into our wholesale markets so whether
they're supporting whether it's federal
support or state support for just regen
and regeneration for solar for wind for
storage all of those pieces are coming
in and the states are justifiably saying
we want to have this is our obligation
this is our bailiwick to manage
how we think about our mix and what are
what we should be investing in as a
society as a as a Commonwealth or
Pennsylvania's case but the more you do
that the more you're bringing in
subsidized units into a competitive
market and to date I would argue that
it's been small enough it's been
incremental enough that it hasn't done
much substantive damage people can feel
free to disagree with me and I think
that's why we are discussing this there
is an argument that we are starting to
see in incremental but substantive
damage to wholesale markets by how much
of these resources are coming out of the
market and when you're looking out five
years ten years it's it's a tsunami so
as I said it's sort of trickling down
from the north but we also have an
alternative energy portfolio standard
here in the Commonwealth and
conversations about how that might be
moving forward when it taps out tops out
2021 so it's it's fundamentally
important to consider how we distorting
markets energy of capacity markets and
what does that do to some of our
important resources for example one of
the nuclear concerns is that you can
have negative energy prices at night
from wind coming on because they are
making their money off the new federal
tax credits and so they just get paid
they're going to send it to just
generate generate generate and what
they're getting on the wholesale market
is somewhat secondary to Justin to
getting that federal tax credit but then
you've got a nuclear unit that's needed
for the next day it's July 6 it's gonna
be stored aneri hot where PGM as a
summer peaking resource market so PGM is
calling out we need you on for tomorrow
but these are fairly inflexible units
nuclear and coal so you've got to start
ramping up the day before but you're
dispatching to a market with very low or
negative prices how does that work to me
I get that pain and so how we deal with
that and that's a big chunk of the
conversations we're having within PJM is
price Reformation on the one hand if
you're sort of a purist you can argue
that the pain coming to clear and and
cold is from gas and that there's
nothing overtly wrong with using LMP as
a market mechanism it's what's worked
well for 20 years it's continuing with
some tweaks to be a pretty good market
but there's a lot of pressure at PJM to
rethink that and think about these
questions about who's setting price and
flexible units are flexible units and
how to deal with some of these market
failures of negative pricing but I would
argue that rather than the tack that
like Ohio has taken or Connecticut and
the conversations around Zacks I think
that's a blunt instrument that it
doesn't drive innovation and very
difficult to get the price right if you
come up with a Zek are you gonna price
it so what I've been arguing at FERC and
on what I argue within the Commonwealth
here is for a price on carbon say all
right maybe we all don't want to think
about price and carbon because it's
because we think that climate change is
a fundamentally important issue but if
you are gonna have a market mechanism
that can protect and remunerated sources
like nuclear put a price on carbon to
put it in the energy market that is a
pretty nimble transparent clever way to
do it drives innovation all operators
can then say alright well we've got this
price of carbon how do we innovate our
own in our own space whether it's called
for CCS or driving efficiency more
efficiency and our gas plants then you
have a price signal that is doing what
it should do rather than this
blunt instrument of as that dropping in
just to support a favored you a favor
technology the
one other issue come in you know we've
had so he we have all these different
pieces coming in as I mentioned the the
do ii ii ii ii see issue with coming out
of first energy we have this question
about state policies but then we and we
had the the FERC do we know poor out of
Scott Perry two or three months ago
there was sort of PG for kick down the
can down the road saying yeah we're not
going to again rate bass coal but we
want our ISO so think about this
question of resiliency that was raised
in that Abidin by secretary Perry but
it's not new to PGM we've long been in
conversations about resiliency and the
value of some of these attributes that
weren't historically valued again it
goes back to the complexity and
modernization of what we're these
markets they're not so sort of
monolithic one attribute markets and
yeah used to be just move some electrons
and hey we have a market but there are a
lot of other attributes out there that
we rationally should be pricing but some
are easier than others and some are
quite difficult and resiliency is want
to properly price but I'd argue that we
need to I think we can get there I think
it's complicated and challenging and
capacity constructs are already very
difficult artificial constructs not true
markets and some of this lends more to
that challenge that you already have in
the capacity markets but there is real
rational reason to valued resiliency
it's not 90 days of fuel on site fuel
which is what secretary Perry was
arguing and he argued to backstop that
he looked back to the 2014 pulled a
vortex and said look there was all this
market failure because of lack of
resiliency and he argued that the 90
days of fuel on site fuel would resolve
that resiliency problem but if you look
at the numbers it doesn't it doesn't
solve that problem the full of vortex
very little of it was actually on the
on the generation side and coal actually
had some challenges coming into the
market there were some frozen coal pile
issues but the but additionally if you
look at where the real resiliency
challenge is it's in the the
distribution and transmission but
particularly distribution end and if you
want to tackle resiliency that's where
you have to tackle it and more broadly
across the whole panoply not simply by
saying the ninety days if you'll make a
difference and we are I'm running short
of time there's a whole host of other
things I wanted to mention your Eevee
infrastructure we're heavily involved
with alternative rate making trying to
think about what the utility the future
looks like decoupling from the
throughput of just more more electrons
and more molecules you move the movie
that defends your revenue base that's
not a sustainable model given especially
given the interests all of us have an
energy efficiency and conservation so
giving more mechanisms for utilities to
think about to restructure what they are
what their business models like that's
an ongoing issue and just a brief one
act forty thinking about solar
Pennsylvania recently passed an in-state
solar requirement and that's in play in
the next two weeks we'll see an
implementation order come out on that
and that's a challenging space that I
may or may not win on so without an if
there's any questions
to accelerate the adoption of electric
vehicles thanks
yeah the my office a heavy book who's
one of them are you fine yeah real
up-and-coming star a young new member of
my staff its chairs the Infrastructure
Committee Committee Subcommittee on the
state's efforts to think about easy
implementation how we saw the chicken
the egg problem and it's not so easy and
okay we've build a bunch of state TV
stations where do we build them how fast
do we build them who owns them and can
you does there's an opportunity for
utilities to own evie charging stations
or should we just carve it out just for
third parties because we don't want to
rake base something that like an Eevee
charging station philosophically I'm
coming down in the middle and I'm hoping
we can find a way to thread the needle
to say that there are plays there's an
opportunity here for utilities to play
in that space but without closing out
for closing third parties and I think it
can't be done ownership we start to
trickle on and it's another very
prescient issue before us on ownership
regeneration historically again with the
Competition Act we said utilities
throughout the generation business but I
when I look at the future look at the
present the future I don't think that
model that black and white hard and fast
silos works very well we've got all this
de ara they've got storage V's all of
that space how do we layer that in and
how do we think about hybrid models that
allow better implementation and better
adoption of minis technologies time for
maybe one more question if we can make
it quick for students at the University
what do you think is the most important
focus for a future energy study yeah it
to me and so much that's an easy answer
systems I you know you have to have all
the particular pieces in place but all
of these challenges are just integration
challenges and I think of all the pieces
none of this is discrete everything
every it's like the whack-a-mole problem
every time I'm dealing with one issue it
bleeds into all others it's good
monetization it's it's yeah I've talked
about removing pipe and that's also
reducing methane emissions and a
critically important piece but you know
what the business structure looked like
so you need technique financially
technical people business technical
human people you need the engineering
that undergirds that you need people who
can really think broadly about tough
choices and how we make these how all of
this works and it is it's a mind-numbing
sort of Gordian knot or pasta plato's
pasta when you try to do it
and you really can as I said deal with
one piece discreetly all of this sort of
has to be brought together and it's the
same I would I grass a little bit on the
the low-income issues that we can't just
deal with low-income issues within the
Commission we got to think of housing
and access and bringing a whole group of
folks together and thinking about that
so we end up being as something of a
social service agency so again there's
nothing that I do in my day-to-day work
that doesn't cross across such ab large
spectrum and getting folks that think
about thinking that things ways and are
creatively thinking about how to
integrate all this as absolutely as
fundamental as I can get for me
[Applause]
thank you Andrew and if we can take a
second just for one more round of
applause thank you very much for Honda
so now my colleague Amanda King is
actually going to tell us about our next
group
I'm just gonna get their slides up give
me a second
okay next we have a panel titled the
imperative of Energy Humanities where
energy engineering and the arts
intersect and I'd like to introduce to
you our professor Cathy Newman she's an
associate professor of English at
Carnegie Mellon University she'll be
moderating our panel today good morning
I'm Kathy Newman I'm faculty in the
English department and I'm gonna
introduce the panel I think they're
gonna sit here and we're gonna take
turns giving some short presentations
Jacob gesslin is a PhD candidate in
literary and cultural studies his
research focuses on 20th and 21st
century American culture and cultures of
energy in his dissertation Jacob
examines literary and visual art that
represents her uses coal ways such as
slurry ash and acid mine drainage to
call attention to environmental
conditions in the history of coal and
Appalachia Abigail E Owen is a historian
of science technology and environment at
CMU she teaches history courses about
the social and political aspects of
water and agriculture and a course
called introduction to environmental
ideas for CMU's minor and environmental
and sustainability studies she is
director of education for the
steinbrenner Institute for environmental
education and research at Carnegie
Mellon University Noah throat is an
assistant professor of anthropology in
the CMU Department of History he holds a
PhD from the University of
wisconsin-madison and he's conducted
extensive ethnographic research in the
Philippines his scholarship and teaching
combined the tools of history
anthropology political and political
ecology to ask how relationships with
the environment are shaped both by
uneven relations of power and by
different ways of knowing valuing and
being in the world my work in the
English department deals with labor
culture material history I'm finishing a
book right now called how the 50s worked
mass culture in the decade the union's
made and I'm curating an art exhibit
that opens
today marks at 200 art that considers
the relationship between capitalism and
culture recognizing the fact that Karl
Marx turns 200 in May of this year so my
presentation asked about the
relationship between culture and energy
what is the history of how we have
cooked our food heated our living spaces
lit up our nights and produced things
that we can enjoy from a cultural point
of view as I began to work at the
intersection of this nexus culture and
energy I become convinced that energy
history must become an integral part of
cultural studies we can't make or enjoy
culture without energy and at the same
time the kinds of culture we produce and
enjoy are dependent upon the available
energy forms at a given moment I want to
start with this very old example
archaeological evidence for the earliest
evidence of cooking with fire has been
traced to the Wonderware cave in South
Africa nearly 1 million years ago this
means that for the first 996 thousand
years of human life the primary fuel for
heating and cooking and the primary form
of energy for creating light in the dark
has been light from a fire or a few
thousand years later light from candles
and oil lamps is it any wonder that the
earliest forms of storytelling were epic
songs poems and dances told and
performed around an open fire quite
often when energy is defined in the
modern era we think in terms of fossil
fuels coal oil and natural gas
so I'm arguing today that if we're going
to think about culture and energy across
time we must broaden the range of what
we think of as energy and so here the
categories I want to sort of briefly
introduce before we move to our panel
energy for light energy for heat energy
for cooking energy for transportation
energy for industry and energy for
electricity so my second argument is
that all forms of culture require energy
for their production to
and consumption to create books we need
heat light today a computer we need the
energy that fuels the factory that makes
paper prints the words and binds the
book we also need the energy that fuels
the shipping of the book and we need
heat and light to make ourselves
comfortable while we read my third
argument is that culture is often
engaged in the project of representation
of telling stories about forms of energy
many of our folktales for example take
place in the woods where for nearly a
million years humans had to forge for
their most important form of fuel
firewood so I'm just gonna zoom us
through some of the history connected to
these different forms in 70,000 beef see
we see the invention of the primitive
oil lamp that was usually burned made of
stone and burned animal fat 29,000 BC we
have the earliest Earth ovens 8,000 BC
we have the earliest evidence of the
pressing and use of olive oil which was
used for cooking and lighting 3500 BC
the first domestication of horses and
the invention of the wheel 3000 BC we
have the earliest known sailing vessels
2000 BC is the we find that the Chinese
were the first to use coal as an energy
source by 1300 BC it is common for homes
in Greece to have a central hearth and
here is a Turkish king who installed
radiant heating in his castle 500 to 200
BC we have developments in lamp and
candle making 200 BC Europeans harness
water energy to power mills in the 10th
century windmills were used in in Persia
and in the early 1400s the first
cast-iron stoves in 1400s the first
chimneys 1590s
the mastery of windmills by the Dutch
1600s the use of coal coke in England so
this really marks a break I want to
point out that for most of human history
firewood an animal fat olive oil were
the primary things that were used to
heat and light and so 1600 1700s is the
big break with coal
there's the increasing reliance on whale
oil and lamps in this period coal
becomes the dominant energy source
17:12 we have the steam engine which
allows us to pump water out of coal
mines which increases the extent to
which we can mine and use coal 1748 the
first commercially produced coal in
Richmond Virginia and this is coal hill
in Pittsburgh what does coal hill called
today who knows Mount Washington 1790s
the beginning of gaslights a steam
engine was invented that because you
could be used to heat homes 1821 first
natural gas well in the US 1825 coal
powered trains 1860 the first solar
powered system invented in France 1863
invention of radiators 1870 the early
Standard Oil well 1882 Edison's Pearl
Street power station 1892 the first
geothermal system built in Boise Idaho
Paris World's Fair features an engine
that can run on peanut oil in 1900 1901
the famous Lucas gusher in Texas 1902 is
Spindletop Texas this is basically a
year later you can see the growth in oil
production and so really here I just at
the end I want to pause and wonder why
at the end of the 1400s there's a
printing revolution was this made
possible by advances in the quality of
lamps and oil that gave writers
inventors and printing press operators
enough light and heat to do their work
it admittedly however the increasing
cultural dominance of books Co silence
with the rise in Western technologies to
extract and harness fossil fuels we also
have movable-type invented in China and
here shows
European output of books by century so
again I I think that the the kind of
explosion in book technology goes with
that sea change we see when we move to
coal as our primary fuel and I'll end
with an example of how culture reflects
trends in energy I just want you to
think about all the folktales that take
place in the woods there's a famous
Korean folk tale called the woodcutter
and the fairy a wish-granting tale the
plethora of woods are dangerous stories
from Robin Hood to Little Red Riding
Hood Hansel and Gretel and Goldilocks
the three bears and the most famous
woodcutters in American history the Tin
Woodman and Paul Bunyan so today please
join me in welcoming our panel that's
going to think more about the connection
between culture and energy Jacob is up
next
thank you
[Applause]
all right so the short talk that I'm
gonna give today is called energy waste
in the public eye using art as advocacy
and it's part of a dissertation that I'm
working on that looks at various ways in
which literary and visual arts talk
about coal waste use or represent
substances like slurry ash and acid mine
drainage as I'm kind of thinking about
the invite contemporary environmental
issues related to coal so to say a bit
more about just kind of where this
project is coming from and thinking
about the way that we kind of think
about climate change in culture I've
noticed two main tendencies and how we
how we talk about these things so the
first is - there's a tendency to kind of
think in terms of global collectivity
that we all kind of share the same air
we all kind of are going to have to deal
with the similar environmental problems
we all share that same you know planets
finite resources and this kind of
coalesce isn't a concept that geologists
have put forward called the Anthropocene
that kind of takes the recent history or
history of fossil fuel use or just
resource use in general and marks a
geological era where we can actually
kind of read the human history and the
geological record so there's this one
tendency that Universal eise's then that
kind of competes with a second kind of
or overlapping tendency that looks very
much at the individual so when we think
about the way in which we respond of can
stop everyday folks kind of can respond
to an issue like climate change we think
about our individual choices as far as
what cars we drive what kind of what we
buy at the supermarket it kind of takes
out you know this global problem and
turns it into something that's very much
kind of something that we can see in
daily life and so there's these two kind
of overlapping tendencies that I've been
thinking through in it then it like what
I've noticed is that there's the absence
of kind of like the way in which
regional histories are kind of specific
areas have their own kind of stories
about kind of fossil fuel use resource
use that are just as much kind of should
be a part of the way
we we think about these these more
global issues in the present so what I'm
going to do is just kind of talk through
a few a few artworks by one particular
artist that I'm writing about right now
this is a kind of example that I thought
was on it has a pretty good kind of
illustration of some of the neat kind of
technical techniques that that artists
are using so this is by the artist John
sobral he's a painter from South East
Ohio and Saburo has worked with an
environmental engineer to develop a
technique where they collect acid mine
drainage out of waterways um kind of
they they look material settle they
spark for certain chemical reactions
that kind of reduce it down to iron
oxide they have purified water that then
they put back into the stream where it
came from and then use the ionic oxides
to create pigments that are used in the
art so you can see a little bit just
kind of about the process here and so
what
Saburo has done is he kind of has
developed a a certain technique where he
lays out aluminum discs and then mixes
this acid mine drainage based pigments
with water and basically starts to kind
of put the water on like drip the water
onto the aluminum disk to our colors
layer and it creates kind of a bubble of
water that then drives over the course
of weeks to kind of leave this resulting
artwork and so we have an example of
this here there's a way that his art
kind of takes something that we would
think of as you know an environment or
that's an environmental hazard kind of
by working through it kind of you know
creates these images that do have a
certain extent of like kind of a natural
beauty especially kind of in this blues
it's something that is a much more kind
of relatable in how we think about
environmental art you can see here as an
example that's a little bit more cosmic
in its colors
all right so what I'm most interested in
is how this art doesn't just kind of
convey an environmental message you
don't get kind of much meaning by just
looking at this art but instead I'm
interested in how something like this or
a series like this spark is an entry
point into initiating a larger
conversation about the environment so in
this case what you have is this this art
on that you know savoir creates these
works of art but also that these are in
the way that he talks about his art in
the way frames is art it's all about the
process that this right here is just a
tool that enables him to speak more
about issues related to acid mine
drainage the ultimate goal that they're
currently working on I think they have a
Kickstarter for this that's almost
funded is basically they're trying to
work to create a large-scale plant to
where they can continue to produce these
paints at a at a at a commercial level
and then use the funds to further clean
up acid mine drainage sites and things
like that
so it's it's the art isn't the kind of
the important thing here it's how it
opens up a conversation on that note I
wanted to include these images here
these don't use the acid mine drainage
pigments but he has another series where
he edges underground mine tunnels onto
onto disks as a way of kind of getting
people to talk about the way in which
we've kind of recorded history
underneath the surface that way that we
kind of have these these images that are
kind of an artifact of the industrial
era that we that we can talk about so
yeah you know I see this as part of a
project that is both kind of helping us
to think through some of the current
environmental problems that relate are
related to fossil fuel use but also just
kind of ways in which we can think about
how culture can help us to think through
some of the the longer-term ways in
which we've used resources and have
related to energy in in our society
thank you
[Applause]
I'm going to talk about some of the how
and energy humanities I'm a historian
and I'm gonna look at some of the
materials that I can use as a historian
to do the work of energy humanities to
think about humanities and also think
about energy and the science and
engineering of it at the same time and
this is one example of knowing the just
enough about the language of science I
think it's really important to know
what's going on inside the world of
science and engineering not to be a
scientist or an engineer but also to be
able to use that language and to
understand just enough to ask our own
questions our own humanities questions
so for example in this diagram which is
a primary secondary school diagram about
the water cycle we can see that
groundwater is really an important part
of the water cycle understanding some
basic language of basic science of
groundwater can help us to understand a
community's relationship to fracking
when perhaps one neighbor has signed a
contract for fracking on their land and
the other neighbor has not so
understanding those social and political
and rhetorical dynamics at the same time
that we understand the geological basis
for disagreements and arguments another
way that there is intersections between
the work of energy the science and
engineering of energy and humanities is
simply by using maps place and space
images and maps are really important
from my discipline history physical
geography are of course really important
for energy energy resources are situated
in physical geography and the crust of
the earth whether it's coal and oil or
shale or whether it's uranium to propel
nuclear reactors people are also
situated in geography so a historian
like me might ask about those people who
are the workers on the oil rigs who are
the coal miners who are the uranium
miners who are the hydroelectric dam
construction crews and what's involved
for the risks that they take another way
of situating people in place and space
is ethnography so understanding people
in their geographic situation and my
colleague Noah Theriot who's an ethic
just might talk a little bit more about
this the humanities give us a lens to
understand relationships between people
place and space one way to do this is
ethnography so for example I love this
book by Madonna Limbert who's an
anthropologist she went to the Sultanate
of Oman which is in the middle of an oil
boom and she wrote this book the time of
oil and Limbert talks to everyday people
in the Sultanate of Oman to find out how
they understand their relationship to
their new financial circumstances how
their life has changed socially as well
as financially their frontiers and their
education but it also understands
changes their understanding of the
future itself these people understand
everyday people understand that oil is
not forever so that is included in their
understanding of the social and cultural
world around them a textbook I really
like to use in teaching is this history
of engineers I wind up teaching a lot of
Engineers undergraduate engineers in my
courses in history and this author
Jessica Teich tracks the projects and
the mindset of engineers who built
California's infrastructures for water
and mines and dams in the late 19th and
early 20th centuries and the author
tracks those same exact engineers the
same people as they traveled and design
big projects all over the world for
example in Hawaii in South Africa and in
Palestine so this study is about
expertise and the way that experts
assume and implement their authority and
engineering for energy projects but for
engineering students who read this kind
of work they wind up getting some
context for how engineers did their work
in the past and they also get the social
context that made a real difference so
they understand that the social
assumptions the social context created a
lot of the situations where engineers
were asked to solve problems and to
create new energy systems and it leads
to some reflection usually on the part
of those undergraduate engineers about
what they're going to do when they leave
the university and when they become
engineers out in the world one way of
talking about energy being situated in
geography in this case a hydroelectric
dam is that the power of the dam is
related to the power of a river which is
a natural system by studying a river and
by studying the humans who have
historically used lived on taking fish
from and understood the river in
different ways
this particular study of the Columbia
River is a classic River biography there
are many River biographies out there
about many different rivers and it puts
dams like the Grand Coulee Dam and the
Bonneville Dam in social historical and
Geographic perspective sometimes dams
create beautiful archives this film
hydro is part of the huge public
excitement about the construction of
dams from 1939 when people were really
excited about electricity showing up in
their homes and businesses and this dam
video is available on YouTube it was
made public by some wonderful archivists
at the Bonneville Power Administration
which is the administration that still
manages the dams in the Columbia River
and this film hydro is usually apparent
to students who are savvy in the ways of
propaganda and media as a propaganda
film about creating a new energy
installation but at the same time it's
also a very beautiful film it takes
advantage of some of the best and the
Works Progress Administration
film experts and it has a full
orchestral score it's really beautiful
and it's really compelling and it
reminds me of some of the stories that
my own grandmother told me about how
excited she was when electricity came to
her rural home maybe 90 years ago she's
no longer around but I remember her
stories and this this film conveys some
of that excitement um digitized records
are also the work of archivists
archivists do really important work for
historians like me also for
anthropologist and literary and cultural
studies they maintain documents and
materials and we live in this era when a
lot of these archives are beautifully
digitized and available to us who want
to study them without having to travel
and without having to handle the
documents with our own hands so here we
have some beautiful archives with
illustrations of fish and canoes
from the journeys of Lewis and Clark on
that same Columbia River and then
sometimes archives give you these little
gifts this photo on the left is a photo
that I found when I was doing research
on a dam that was investigated by the
World Bank and the Curt the past
director of the World Bank Robert S
McNamara had visited this dam and I
found this photograph which I thought
that was really beautiful of him
overlooking the dam the rest of the
archives of the dam were quite boring
contracts and numbers and tables and
memos that I had a hard time
understanding but then I saw Steven
Spielberg's beautiful movie the post
about a particular moment in 1971 and I
realized that the actor and the costume
designer a set designer had done a
really good job investigating what
exactly Robert S McNamara might look
like
dressed like and moved like in that era
so archives sometimes can give you gifts
like that
[Applause]
good morning everyone
I'm Noah Theriot from the CMU Department
of History and my talk is entitled from
Standing Rock to Susquehanna how the
environmental humanities can illuminate
the politics of energy so thank you all
for coming um I'd like to thank dr.
Newman for organizing the panel the
energy rig organizers for including us
in the lineup and also those whose labor
keeps this campus clean safe and
functioning day in and day out I'd also
like to acknowledge the land on which
we're gathered today for thousands of
years it's been the land of indigenous
peoples including peoples whose names
have been lost a conscious memory as
well as to the Cisco Hana Kahn nashoni
and other nations at various points in
time today this region remains home to
many indigenous persons from across
Turtle Island and I would like to
express my gratitude to this land and
its indigenous Guardians for the
opportunity to live work and form
kindred here even as I remain an
uninvited guest I wanted to begin today
with a land acknowledgement not only
because it's important to recognize the
settler colonial condition of our
society but also because it helps orient
us to the perspective that the
environmental humanities bring to
conversations about energy my aim today
is to show why we need anthropology
history and philosophy and in particular
why we need the perspectives of
indigenous scholars in these fields if
we want to understand the disputes that
surround energy extraction and transport
in North America today these disputes I
want to suggest are about more than how
the costs and benefits of particular
projects or industries are distributed
and they're about more than climate
change to understand what's at stake and
the seemingly irreconcilable struggles
were seen in places like Standing Rock
to our West and the Susquehanna Valley
to our East
we need to sensitize ourselves to the
historical cultural and ontological
context in which these struggles unfold
let's begin by considering a proposition
that rose to prominence amid the
struggle at Standing Rock water is life
a translation of the Lakota principal
mini which Oni although I cannot speak
for Chet ISA Cohen water protectors or
for any indigenous communities I want to
suggest that water is life is more than
a protest slogan and more than a true is
about the ubiquity of water as a
necessity for life it's an ontological
proposition about the nature of being
and about the distribution of life or
vitality in the world only when we
understand this proposition as such can
we begin to fully appreciate what's at
stake in resistance to energy projects
like the Dakota access pipeline as
everyone here is surely aware we live in
a time of rapid if volatile expansion of
oil and gas extraction in North America
from the tar sands in Canada to the
shale plays of the u.s. planes in the
Northeast along with this comes an
expansion of associated infrastructures
from the drilling rigs and the
pipeline's whose proliferation over vast
areas is provoking intense controversy
to the adjacent industry is like the
ethane cracker being built about 150
miles to our east part of what makes
these infrastructures controversial are
the physical risks that they posed the
nearby communities from those living in
the so-called blasto zones to those
whose soil and water may be contaminated
another controversial aspect of course
is the connection to climate change with
many calling for a scaling down rather
than an expansion of fossil fuel
development and yet another still is the
question of property rights with some
landowners angered over the use of split
estates forced pooling eminent domain
and other tactics to override their
dissent these are the sorts of concerns
we are most likely to encounter in media
accounts of what happened at Standing
Rock and all of these issues over
physical security health regulatory
fairness and property rights should
inform our understanding of what
happened there but what many media
accounts and commentaries
did not address is what in my analysis
matters most the long-standing struggle
for indigenous sovereignty in response
to violent colonial occupations and
indigenous conceptions of personhood
kinship and accountability that informed
that struggle in the case of Standing
Rock the Dakota access pipeline was more
than a potentially hazardous
infrastructure project it was the latest
chapter in a long story of dispossession
and forced relocation from the US Army's
1863 master massacre of Sioux persons at
white stone hill to the arm u.s. Army
Corps of Engineers dam projects that
altered sacred rivers and displaced
communities in the 1950s in the words of
olala olala lakota historian LaDonna
brave bull Allard
the sacred stone camp at Standing Rock
quote where the Cannonball River joins
the Missouri River at the site of our
camp today there used to be a whirlpool
that created large spherical sandstone
formations the stones are not created
anymore ever since the US Army Corps of
Engineers dredged the mouth of the
Cannonball River and flooded the area in
the late 1950s as they finished though
Oh a dam they killed a portion of our
sacred River Potawatomi scholar Kyle Paz
white adds that stopping da PL was about
stopping a vicious pattern of u.s.
colonialism that inflicts immediate
environmental harms and future climate
change impacts on indigenous peoples
unquote so we need to bear in mind the
history behind all of this and that's
obviously something that the humanities
can bring to the table but we also need
to understand what's at stake
ontologically in August 2016
voil Lakota scholar activist I used in
Houston American Horse wrote quote our
elders have told us that if the zoo Zeca
Safi the black snake comes across our
land our world will end
sir Zeca has come in the form of the
Dakota access pipeline and so I must
fight unquote his invocation of the
black snake points to the cosmological
and ontological underpinnings of
resistance to the pipeline calling
themselves protectors and not protestors
the resistance bio-jet ISA Cohen and
their allies cannot be reduced to a
defense of nature in the Western sense
of a pristine wilderness nor to a
protection of water as an inanimate
object or resource nor for that matter
to a defense of territory LaDonna brave
will bat brave bull Allard points out
that the pipeline threatened to
desecrate quote places held sacred not
only by the Sioux nations but also by
the ark hara the Mandan and the Northern
Cheyenne unquote this sacredness comes
in part from the inhabitation of these
places by divine beings writing of the
philosophies of great plains nations
Blackfeet matey's scholar Rosalind
lapier observes that quote the Blackfeet
viewed water as a distinct place a
sacred place it was the home of divine
beings and defying animals who taught
the Blackfeet religious rituals and
moral restrictions on human behavior it
can in fact be compared to Mount Sinai
of the Old Testament which was viewed as
ground and where God gave Moses the Ten
Commandments unquote
but the sacredness also comes from the
role that these places play in
maintaining kin relations that extend
far beyond those one might have with
one's living human kin linking the
standing rock water protectors to the
idol no more and the black lives matter
movement dakota scholar kim tall bear
describes all three of these movements
as having been founded by a quote badass
women who caretake relations unquote the
relation she's referring to our kin
relations but as a dakota scholar she
uses kin in in ways that contradict
patriarchal white settler ideas of
kinship according to in her words the
kin in question are the spirits of
ancestors generations yet to be unborn
and other than human relatives of many
different forms so with all of this in
mind we can understand that resistance
to the pipeline was to a significant
degree about honoring these more than
human kin relations and protecting them
from an existential harm of cosmological
proportions it's worth recalling here
that colonialism is not just a project
of material territorial and ideological
subjugation it's also an ontological and
cosmological project one that seeks to
subjugate and eliminate indigenous
worlds tall bear further writes that in
addition to the genocide of islands that
settler colonialism has effected in
North America quote another eliminatory
tactic has been to sever our sustaining
relations with our other than human
relatives unquote political theorist
Audra Mitchell describes such acts of
severance as transversal violence
suggesting how colonial projects
involved not just physical coercion and
erasure but also the imposition of
colonial temporalities cosmologies and
ontology
time being and the cosmos itself are at
stake we can appreciate then that what
was at stake at Standing Rock was also
more than a culturally significant
landscape it was the very power to
determine and enact what constitutes
life elizabeth poe Vannelli describes
this as Gionta power which she writes
operates through the regulation of the
distinction between life and non-life
u.s. settler colonial society operates
according to a secular biological
conception of life and
human Exceptionalist possessive
individualist conception of personhood
to say nothing of the racialized hetero
patriarchal structures through which
these conceptions have been variegated
these conceptions fundamentally shape
how our institutions function and they
fundamentally shape how we relate to one
another to other than human beings and
to the land itself and these relations
are fundamentally different from those
that were being defended at standing
rock life itself is what's at stake in
the politics of energy today and this is
why water is life is much more than a
slogan this is this challenging
proposition but it's one that the
environmental humanities can help us
face thank you I think each one of you
to know your opinion it says what should
scientists and engineers learn or apply
from a humanities approach
well I would say along the lines of what
I argued in my talk that it's just you
can apply a sensitivity to the fact that
different communities have very
different worldviews oftentimes and not
just in terms of sort of surface level
cultural differences that were that
we're fairly familiar with but sometimes
at the very fundamental level of like
different ontological assumptions about
the composition of reality and the place
of humans or sort of communities of
beings in relation to their landscapes
and to one another so I think it's about
cultural sensitivity and a sense that
what's at stake is not just resources
but sometimes something like more
intangible or difficult to measure say
with the tools of economics or social
sciences for example a hundred years ago
eugenics the science of race and racial
hierarchy was taught in universities as
a real science this was a hundred years
ago and there were engineers who were
doing projects they were implementing
these concepts these social assumptions
at the same time that they were doing
their dam construction or their
community building or sat on that
building and for engineers to learn
about this to learn that a hundred years
ago engineers who were doing good work
solving engineering problems were also
reflecting and using and implementing
these other social ideals is really
powerful for engineers to learn about
and to understand because it makes them
reflect on what might be the social
context what might be the social
assumptions in their own time that they
are reflecting and furthering without
perhaps even realizing it something that
I'd like to add is just I think that
something that the art that I look at it
brings to the table is is a way that
kind of encouraging us to think in a
different time scale
so thinking both you know we think often
about like what the life of a certain
project might be but something that I
think it's interesting about the acid
mine drainage project in particular is
how that brings together you know a
century you know at least a century of
resource use in the region that it's
it's something that you know we see this
this art that's based and based on this
substance that's been in the process of
being created for a hundred years and so
in not to mention coal itself so we have
just these ways in which these kind of
objects these cultural objects can just
help us think more thoroughly about
about time yeah I would add to that an
observation about time I think something
that I found really humbling about
thinking about the timeline of the
relationship between culture and energy
is how short the fossil fuel age has
been and while we're incredibly
dependent on these technologies now most
of human history has been without the
kind of resources we take for granted
and that we are running out of so a lot
of our dystopian narratives imagine a
world beyond fossil fuels like Walking
Dead there's not a lot of electricity
and Walking Dead for example so I just
want us to be humble in our thinking
about what is our right to these
resources and for and that we've had
them for a very short time and that we
may not have them for much longer it's
related to to these how do we build
curriculum to reflect this philosophy
curriculum
I think that providing accessible
historical examples is one way to relate
to humans in the past and see how we
might be doing things differently or the
same right now it's it's a great
awareness builder I think history I'm a
historian of course is is without
parallel in that case so I think that
knowing how we got to where we are and
also being really conscious about where
we're at and what our discussions for
the future are and seeing that in fact
we are embedded in some social
assumptions and some mindsets is really
important I also think that having
language to cross disciplines is part of
this so for Humanities I think having
the language of science as part of our
discussion not to be a scientist is
important and I think the same for
science and engineering having the
language of humanities understanding
what a close reading is what a critical
reading is what an image analysis is
what is social analysis is I think that
all of this is really important so
getting some of each and each and on
that note I also think that issues like
energy in the environment are something
that you know cuts across disciplines so
well that it's enables students to kind
of not just kind of not just think about
their you know their immediate work but
to how their work connects to you know
range of disciplines and how they can
draw from that
so in teaching first-year writing
classes based on some of these topics
it's interesting to see folks who you
know might not you know enter it into
this semester wanting to think about
social problems at all
walk away understanding the way in which
engineering is you know very much
connected to these these decisions we
make as a society as far as how we use
resources so it's it's a way that we can
just kind of as Abigail said have that
common language that we can connect all
of these different approaches to
problems together
yeah yeah and then you know the next
class I'm teaching is on waste and so
you know that's again something that's
very much a cultural object that we see
in our everyday lives that that touches
and touches on designed on on
engineering on you know all of these
kind of problems so it's again this
common symbol that's come in something
that allows us all to come together to
think about broader and my apologies
I'll just talk very briefly about a
class that I teach called environmental
literature it's a 19th century
literature class and I make the students
go on five nature walks during the
course and the walk has to be at least
an hour and they can't bring technology
on their walk and students have told me
it's the hardest assignment they've ever
been given at Carnegie Mellon so I think
what we're all trying to do is really
kind of peel things back and take
students just kind of remove again some
of the things we've become dependent on
pond to think about what what was the
Rose experience and even if we can't
recreate it what would it mean to be
without our technology for an hour thank
you very much to our panelists
fascinating talk thank you
[Applause]
so we have actually reached our first
break of the day it's lunchtime so what
we're going to do is you all are
currently in rangos 1 & 2 directly
behind that wall is rangos 3 and that is
where lunch is so the way that we do
this is we go out these two doors to the
side back into rangos 3 there are buffet
lines so pick up your lunch bring it
back with you and we will get started
promptly at 11:45 11:45 so we'll see you
in less than 30 minutes thank you
you
I'm gonna disconnect this temporarily so
so you're gonna with your clicker you're
gonna move it yep
any of you move their mouse you're gonna
see this click it there - click it there
think it's here or they get here so you
have to move to move it to get ya go
down there and then what am i clicking
there okay this is moving Springs so I'm
gonna connect you okay so I go one two
there look at looking real changing I
was just checking I'm sorry for a minute
okay I was gonna just put it up put it
down now I'm gonna put it all down there
exercise
yes thank you so much
it should be
so everyone we're we're going to get
started in about two minutes so if
you'll take your seats we're going to
get started in about two minutes
[Music]
good afternoon mmm good afternoon
everyone I'm Anna Steve Ken I'm the
Associate Director for innovation and
strategic partnerships for the Scott
Institute for energy innovation we are
very glad to have you here for this
lunchtime lecture I am NOT doing the
formal introduction today but I am here
for a bit of housekeeping in front of
you on the table you'll actually see a
note about an a website that we're using
to collect questions so if you have a
question for one of our for either our
speaker or our moderator you can
certainly put that information you put
slide o comm into your browser you put
in the code pound C mu energy which is
the same as all of our social media in
the case you're doing that today and the
questions will come to the moderator on
stage so with that I'd like to introduce
Christine Monde or she is a CMU alum a
CMU adjunct professor and she's also the
principal and co-founder of evolve EA
which is an architecture and planning
firm here in Pittsburgh Thank You
Christine thanks Anna
so I have the pleasure today of
introducing the CEO of philips Lighting
Chris white and to come on home if I can
tell you a little bit about Chris
exactly look how he comes Chris white is
the fairly recently named president of
the Americas presidency Americas for
philips Lighting and he's responsible
for accelerating the company's
leadership position and expanding the
role of the region is a critical hub of
economic growth and innovation if I
understand correctly you manage all
commercial and operational activities
across the company's entire portfolio
from conventional and led products to
connected systems and services and to
advance the success of Philips in North
South and Central America big region
you are a recognized thought leader on
the positive disruptive effects on the
increasingly digital and connected world
because has done a TED talk online I
recommend and he brings a unique
perspective to the Internet of Things
which is helping the company further
expand its connected lighting offerings
Chris is held the number of
transformative executive roles
throughout his career prior to joining
philips Lighting he was a 20-year
veteran of Cisco where he held various
leadership roles including senior vice
president of global sales strategy and
go to market the Internet of Things
where he spearheaded Cisco's market
influence and leadership in IOT and
before that he was the general manager
of sports and entertainment group which
under his leadership grew from a 20
million dollar company to a 500 million
dollar business in less than five years
so with that let's hear from Chris thank
you thank you good afternoon and great
to see everybody it's a amazing
experience to be here at Carnegie Mellon
thank you for that great introduction
it's always as I hear you know your bio
I'm like is that really me I'm like so
hopefully I can live up to that
expectation so in the next 15 minutes my
objective is to hopefully change your
perspective of light and one kind of
corny way I could do it is turn the
lights off and do this presentation in
the dark and share the value of light
but I think you will get that but light
and the whole lighting industry is going
through yet another amazing
transformational journey a lot of people
get the fact that old incandescent
lighting that philips has been a pioneer
and innovative for over a hundred and
twenty years in has gone through its
first major transition going to LED
lights and most of us see the value and
understand what LEDs can do for us from
a longevity perspective and a quality of
light however now that entire ecosystem
is being connected and for someone that
has been in the industry in the world of
IOT for the last couple of years some of
you probably know some of the
predictions already we all feel fairly
connected to the Internet
day however the predictions are 20
billion 50 billion maybe 200 billion
things are being connected to the
internet over the next three to five
years and on the one hand that sounds
crazy amazing and that you know is that
even possible but then every day in taxi
cabs around the worlds in conversations
over dinner
my son has a connected basketball
my father-in-law has connected hearing
aids we all have connected thermostats
many of you hopefully have connected
lighting at your home through our
success in the consumer channel with
with the hue product which is the number
one connected product around a lexer is
an example so voice-activated lighting
but I want to give you a lighting tour
here of the lighting world is this today
I want to share with you some of the
innovation of the future and I do want
to achieve two things one get you
thinking differently about light but I
also would challenge you all to start
acting differently about light because
if we're really going to all take
advantage of this thing called IOT or
digitization or connected lighting we've
got to do certain things a little
differently and as you go through this
presentation and as we get into the QA
hopefully you'll kind of be thinking
about that and as we turn this into a
discussion not just a one-way
conversation but a couple of data points
right light it's an interesting dilemma
so light is a major consumption of power
around the world probably the largest
18% of the world's energy is consumed
through light sources so there's a huge
amount of pressure to reduce the amount
of energy that light consumes yet there
is exponential demand for light right so
so the predictions is more as the
population this planet grows there's
actually one sobering data point there's
1.2 billion people that don't have
access to regular energy or light
sources so there's a huge demand just
there but as the whole world urbanized
is we're looking at more and more light
sources hitting the world so therefore
thinking through the energy implications
the social implications the building
implications are not to be
underestimated
this is a little bit of I'm a mom and
I'm an exercice you have an axe Britta
I'm an X California and I'm moving to
the East Coast with Phillips
this I don't know anyone recognize where
that bridge is around the world any
Californians in the room Bay Bridge
thank you that is the Bay Bridge that
got lit up actually interesting ly
enough through my background with a
Cisco data center and a philips lighting
infrastructure on the one hand got
phenomenal recognition great lighting up
another iconic tourist place but also
there's a little bit a bit of bit of
anxiety in that community as well you
know there's homeless people in San
Francisco there are some urban issues in
San Francisco
should you be investing in a tourist
area so what we did was partner with the
city and actually s AP and have come up
with a social media tracking device on
this device so the city can actually see
how many tweets Instagram social media
images or activations are used both in a
positive light and a negative light are
people tweeting this says what a waste
of money and this is terrible
are they taking photos saying oh my god
what a beautiful icon I'm going to come
back to San Francisco and thank goodness
that the positive feedback has been very
good and they're using that as a way to
help understand how they can connect
with the community understand what
tourism needs are for the future but
it's just an example of the idea of just
lighting a structure up is pretty cool
understanding what impact it has on
society or a community let alone the
economics of a community hopefully is
even more impactful and better to get a
little excited and hopefully to let let
lunch digest a little bit I want to
share with you a little bit of a video
we're so excited of this digital
transformation we're actually going to
change the name of our company next
month and this is a bit of a teaser on
that with regard to if I can get the
video okay she told me that's it the
wiggle the finger no I got that I missed
the wiggle of finger piece I got it okay
so hopefully the audio will come through
let's not play this very short short
video that we'll share with you a little
bit of what the transformation is all
about
one more time can I can do this wiggle
your finger press the play button that's
been dead
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you there's a village people in
the room that started clapping first by
the way so there was just it's just to
clarify what that means we're actually
keeping our brand names right - using
the Philips brand in certain areas still
but from a company perspective philips
Lighting spun off from Royal Philips
almost its two-year anniversary is
coming up next month as an example so
we're the largest publicly-traded
lighting company in the world today
we've got a very five percent to spend
an investment on R&D we believe the
combination of innovation in lighting
and combining that with the value and
impact of connected lighting has
tremendous impact on this world and in
business in general
hence the hence the name change which
will become official next month after it
goes through a little bit of European
legislative issues so let's talk about
why our world is changing I think some
of this is no no surprise at all to this
great audience here obviously a
population growth means people need more
light light there is also though a
challenge of how much that resource is
consuming therefore how can you make it
even more efficient and energy efficient
and use less of the resources that are
out there to make sure this planet keeps
going but then also there's the idea of
what does digital innovation do to that
as things digitally go from analog to
digital I think we all know the rate of
change changes dramatically it's not
just a linear change it's an exponential
change and sometimes we all have trouble
getting our heads around probably not
with this esteemed audience but I do
thinking about how do you think and act
exponentially how do you plan for
exponential change our architects our
design people our buildings are set your
beautiful building just down the road is
a multi-year process by the time that
building starts compared to when people
walk into that building the technology
has changed dramatically so how do we
think differently an architect
differently and collaborate differently
to take advantage of that I wanted to
give you a couple of few examples of
that obviously the population growth and
urbanization with cities is putting a
lot of pressure on city infrastructure
how could light and the
infrastructure help transform that I
know we have the mayor of San Juan here
I just had a meeting with her this
morning phenomenal passion and desire to
help get that community in that country
out of the tough times it had off to the
hurricane but she's also thinking
through as a thought leader of how do
you take advantage of that and put in a
digital infrastructure how do you put in
a connected infrastructure that if that
terrible accident happens again
how do you how do you how do you how do
you get how do you get back on line
quicker how do you get lighting to
communities quicker how do you get power
to communities quick I had to get food
to connect it so this whole idea of
connecting communities that typically
operate in silos is a great area what
we're excited about is think of the
light infrastructure both inside a
building and outside the building I
spent 20 years at a networking company
that was pretty proud of plumbing the
internet and putting together the first
generation of the internet and the great
impact that had think now of the next
generation whether you call it IOT or
digitization the need for connecting the
world with 5g technology that the telcos
and people are some some people are
excited about enough some people a
little nervous about that
5g as an example needs 10 times the
density of cell towers than the current
cellular technology so you think about
the impact that might have on a
beautiful campus like this you know do
you want to see 10 times the amount of
ugly cell towers designed as poor poor
poor imitations of plastic trees around
this because campus as an example and
what we've tried to do is innovate and
partner with other other other private
entities and we've announced a
partnership with this company called 88
ICI American Tower corporation American
Tower corporation their lost business
model was designing those ugly towers
but typically they're in areas with not
many people see we've now designed a
light pole that actually can be
beautifully our tech Arctic
architectural II designed but you can
open that light bulb up and put 5g
antennas or low-band
IOT Internet towers or Wi-Fi Wi-Fi
antennas into the structure and
therefore cover to cover the area
without impacting the community etc the
efficiency side obviously is
is doings Philips are ourselves we have
shipped two billion LED light sources
already and that's made a difference but
then there are certain consumption
issues or infrastructure issues that how
do you keep going and how do you
actually get to that next generation of
what connecting light can really be all
about and how do you make an even bigger
impact with that so I wanted to kind of
share with you some examples of what
digital innovation is already happening
and I want to finish on hopefully
stretching your thoughts about future
waves of innovation that can leave we
haven't even figured out how to how to
implement and benefit from yet so let's
start at the home anyone here have a
connected lighting system in their home
today few early adopters in the room
that's good to hear
right and the idea of connected
connected lighting and connected home
right it's not actually new right the
smart home has been talked about for
decades right Sony and Panasonic of this
world you know a couple of decades ago
got all excited about it and technology
wasn't together then the home networking
market that I was a part of a couple
years ago called excited about it but
now with things like Alexa and nest
thermostat and connected lighting it's
becoming a reality
you can actually use your cell phone
device to control your home and I want
to kind of stretch your thinking a
little bit because some people in the
audience are probably sitting there
saying you know seriously you need a
connected light bulb you can't get up
and turn the light switch on enough but
there are multiple benefits of a
connected lighting system in the home
one actually is safety and security if
you think about it right you know how
many people have tried that gorgeous
system of getting one of those a timers
in your wall and putting a thing when
you go on vacation right you know I got
a news flash right the criminal world
has figured out you know if they sit
outside your house for two days in a row
and that lightbulb just goes on and off
you're not home right so the idea or the
connected system is why not mimic it the
way you live in that home so set a
pattern that says when I come home the
lights in the kitchen go on because it
because I'm making making dinner then
I'm gonna go to the front room and watch
TV for an hour and then that lights
going to go off and I'm going to the
bedroom for half an hour and I'm in bed
and it gives the impression of a more
secure livable livable room think about
any one of us that have elderly parents
if you could help control the lighting
environment so as it gets dark you can
turn the lights on for your elderly
elderly
relations and improve the environment
they live in the idea of this has gone
into the hospitality area right anyone
that travels around the world one of the
worst things in them is is to get up in
the middle of the night hit the light
switch and be blinded and woken up when
you're trying to just survive through
the night and get as much sleep as
possible well certain new hospitals have
put it sorry new hotels of putting
senses in the room now so as you get up
but a dull light comes on you can go to
the bathroom you can turn the lights air
conditioning up or down you go back to
bed and relax so the spectrum is huge
the other end for any entertainments any
sort of Netflix junkies any movie buffs
in the room so we demonstrated at CES
where this can connect to your
entertainment system so the idea is pick
your favorite movie you're gonna watch a
movie right you dull the lights every
most people now I've got these beautiful
TVs with surround sound systems what if
the lighting system interacted with that
movie what if we demonstrate this with
Wonder Woman right you're sitting in a
dark room watching a movie as an
explosion goes off all your lights go
off is what would go on as well the
immersive experience is incredible any
music people if you're listening to your
favorite band in a concert the light
show in your house is exactly the same
as what is going on in stage so there's
these two huge extremes is a very
pragmatic practical example and then
there's this very inspirational
immersive entertainment value but let's
bring it back into the business world
and into into into buildings like this
this is Deloitte's
corporate headquarters in in the Benelux
actually and talks about a connected
lighting system but they didn't just
connect the light system they gave every
employee an app to be able to control
that system so you can control the
lighting or in the environment this is
proved to be one of the most sustainable
buildings in Europe it's also proved to
be one of the most efficient buildings
in Europe and people like the
environment because you can adjust the
lighting to increase the energy level
and increase the productivity of people
in that in that area city of LA went to
a connected lighting system I've seen a
10% reduction in crime because guess
what crime happens in dark unsecured
neighborhoods so if you can increase the
lighting area in in the cities things
improve
Huntington Beach is an early pioneer
this is one of those light poles that I
talked about before right embedded in
that light bulb is a 5g antenna a wife
via a Wi-Fi antenna a shot detection
antenna an environmental antenna to
create a better environment in a
community to finish on a little bit to
think a little bit different and some of
the future technologies so solar-powered
light we've worked with areas in India
in some of the light starved villages so
kids can do their homework at night
in fact you worked that in South America
to provide light to Stadium so kids can
play soccer in the evenings there's this
great technology we just showed last
week at a light and build of two weeks
ago called life I life I uses the power
of light to distribute the Internet at
the moment it's being demonstrated a 30
to 40 megabyte pace so the idea of that
light source that delivers will Wi-Fi
and data to that table
it doesn't distribute it everywhere so
it's very secure it's very focused
future technologies on infrared say that
could be up to three gigabits type of
transmission but also with this lighting
infrastructure you should be able to
tell how many people are in this room
what they're doing linking with the
infrastructure to adjust the
air-conditioning as a retailer you can
figure out where you are in the store
and deliver 30 centimeter location
accuracy using light versus other
technologies and then the other thing
we've got to do where I'll finish on is
we have to feed this world so light put
light sources and the way we use
horticultural lighting to make things
grow as efficiently and as effectively
as impossible hopefully as allows us to
feed the world as well so in that
lightning recession there I know we want
to turn this into an interactive session
so I'll come join you on the couch thank
you for listening hopefully you do think
of lighting a little bit differently and
I'll come join you where do you want to
sit all right well let's give them hands
first
so I get to pick your brain a little bit
and so I'm gonna ask this know much
there so be careful short short session
ok that's great we're done I'm gonna ask
you some questions about how Phillips is
thinking about these things not just
from a product aspect but also from how
you do business
yep connect it back to how the
university connects and then talk about
kind of how this scales in the future so
first we've heard some interesting ideas
about change models um in the past
presentations yesterday and the day
before I'd say if I had to paraphrase
how people talked about it some people
talked about their company's is kind of
virtuous innovators other ones are
profit driven implementers crisis
disruption is another model of change
code driven change you know there's a
number of different ways that companies
are thinking about or researchers are
thinking about how their their offerings
are gonna be taken up in the market how
where does fits Philip's fit in this
continuum and how do you all think about
yeah it's it's a great great question
and actually I think it's it's it's the
right question too because you know
being a publicly traded company now
there are certain pressures on you to
deliver results and continue to be
successful but hopefully that doesn't
distract you from your core values and
your on your core focus and one of
Phillips Lighting's core values and
focus is innovation in lighting and the
benefit of lighting and so I'm actually
pretty proud and I've only been here at
90 days type thing but the the balance
seems to be a very good one and
hopefully the the pressure of being a
private sector company can put the right
sort of pressure on the innovation
engine because more and more that
innovation needs to be aligned with the
needs of a community or the business
otherwise it's not commercially viable
yeah
so I think hopefully I think we've got a
we got a pretty good balance on
you know we don't want to just innovate
for innovations sake yeah but we're
trying to make sure it's it's it's it's
it's a benefit to the planet and the
commercial side as well as the
educational side so if your change model
is is is you know connected to both
community and to product innovation into
profit obviously as well how is that
happening internal and I'll I'll say one
of the great things about Carnegie
Mellon is that you know we have people
from all different disciplines I'm an
architect and designer and thinking
about how people make urban environments
but I was talking to one of my
colleagues 10 years ago who was working
in material sciences she's talking about
boy you know we're just we need to get
to this point before these cool things
she's doing which eventually led to led
um
just weren't there yet and so we
recognized there was a gap between what
where we were I'm here who is Philips is
kind of that the organization right now
that's filling that gap right between
material science and implementation who
is on the team in Philips
who what kind of thinking are you doing
how is this different than your
traditional model of doing business
because you're selling your bulbs in a
computer store not in a hardware store
yes yeah no boy there's multi dimensions
to that question it's a great one you
know I think one if you look at the
internal side of a company like Philips
we now have multiple layers of where we
both innovate and interact with the
market and this is why I love doing
events like this right you know that the
challenge do you think differently and
keep up to date with an amazing
Institute's like this as far as how much
outreach they want to do how much
private partnerships do you want to
really roll your sleeves up and doing
but you know in certainly with regard to
Philips though we have you know a chief
innovation officer that is looking a
little further out you know looking all
around the world in China and India in
the u.s. in Europe to figure out what
are some of the new technologies and
disruptive factors that are happening
whether it be in in lighting innovation
or chip innovation or artificial
intelligence or robotic implementation
right those that those are colliding
when it comes to a a regional basis we
try and roll off
leaves up with both customers education
and again an innovation engine whether
it is startup community that got very
well profile here this week and make
sure we're not missing anything and so
the the multi dimensions now we want to
make sure we're not so proud of our
heritage and innovation that we get
stuck into the good ol not invented here
syndrome but then you know it's a very
very very careful balance actually I
think nowadays but but but what I
thought what if comfortable within one
of the reasons I joined the company is I
like the idea of you know let's let's
let's stick to our knitting so to speak
and realize there's so much innovation
going on in lighting and disruption
going on there and then let's not be
naive to what digital disruption does so
therefore as an example we've launched
an IOT platform with open API is to
other people so they can you know plug
into that community and both by the way
on the on the on the corporate side as
well as the home side so we have a whole
developer community for cold friends of
hue that can come up with cool
applications to use lighting that you
know we would never have come up with
without that ecosystem and community
yeah so you really need to create that
ecosystem to support your product which
is so much more complex than when it was
just providing lighting it is I don't
more other points I think it's a very
valid one right you know lighting in a
computing store and one of our one of
our challenges we move digitally is the
consumption of lighting at the moment
because historically we typically would
have gone to you know a major building
supplier or you know our standard
electrical play and all of a sudden it
does need to be in a computerized
environment and take that into the
business world and your background of
design and architecture right it's like
okay how do we talk differently to the
architectural community and the design
community to think differently about you
know it's not just you know 6,000 light
points in this room right what could you
do with you know 8,000 connected ones
that understand how that's linked to the
heating system or the tracking system to
get more efficiency and a better
experience in a room like this so I
think you did a great job actually of
connecting to the urban environment you
know we're not talking about just the
technology we're talking about the role
of it within the environment
another one of our assets here at CMU
jolt our has done Studies on how
lighting changed the way we behave in
cities when we first got electrification
so that's that's a big difference what
do you see as the future what's
different in a city not just visually
but performative ly because we're
implementing new technologies yeah and
there's multiple layers to that I think
one of the things you just alluded to
and we've done some of our own research
and partnered with some educational
establishments around the world to
understand the impact of light on our
lives and you know as a next Northern
European that has the benefit of living
in California for the last couple of
years I could just tell you personally
right you know you wake up in dreary wet
old England and it's never like that
here my drive here but you know contrast
that to being you know vitamin D over
overdosed in California you know you
wake up with an energy right so think
about to your point okay if you don't
have the benefit of good old California
weather how can you use light to change
that environment and Literary we've done
we've done studies and now some of our
connected lighting will literally do
that right so and we're actually trying
to figure out what the transition from
getting up in the morning all the way to
going to work is so our hue system has
been designed to be bright and
energizing when you wake up to be
relaxing when you when you come in but
to be intense enough if you want to read
a good book take that into the the the
the war that the business world for a
minute or the educational mode for that
matter you know we're probably all
drinking a little too much caffeine
nowadays to try and keep that energy
going
well what about using light to stimulate
and keep your brain and the endorphins
moving in the right direction so and I
think that just moves into the community
as well right and so the idea of
connected lighting in a city has
multiple effects one bring light to
impoverished areas bring light
efficiency by able to control those
lights but don't do it at the expense of
the experience we had a cardiff city
small city in south wales the capital
actually at our leadership conference a
couple weeks ago and the gentleman
was fantastic because he talked about
the benefit of a connected light system
but even he didn't didn't understand so
the idea is we're trying to conserve
energy but if there's an accident can
you give police access to that system to
turn up the lights to bring safety in
get people out get the thing clear it up
and then drop it down again you know if
you're at a restaurant at a you know
having a nice dinner on your anniversary
you don't want a light just going in
there so they've given retail
establishments access to the lighting so
they can dull it during that peak hours
but then when they want to get everyone
home safely they turn it up brightly
again and people get out of that city so
I think there's really interesting sort
of community benefits and impacts and
one final one I'll talk about which I
don't even think about is the benefit of
light to the deaf and blind community
people in Cardiff go down the pub and
have a drink if they're if they're if
they're using sign language they can
communicate in an environment like that
as soon as they work out and there's bad
light they come yeah that's Jay you know
blind people they don't need light but
their guide dogs need light to be safe
to take them home so it's just a
fascinating example of what connected
lighting has multiple benefits in a
community so that makes me think about
how important it is here in the
university that we already do a good job
working across units and I'm reminded
that our colleagues that came up just
before this presentation were from
humanities and you know you heard more
than once that that part of their role
is understanding how this is situated in
the cultural ethical matrix of things
we're we're technological optimists your
technological optimist what what
concerns or worries or challenges do you
think we have with as we're so
optimistic about adopting new
technologies yeah that's a great
question we're just having this
conversation on the work over actually
because I do I class myself as a digital
optimist I'll put a plug to plug in for
a gentleman that I don't know that well
but Peter Diamandis wrote this book
abundant so you've seen it it's it's
it's it's called the future is brighter
than you think nothing to do with
lighting at all by the way but it just
talks about digital adoption solving
some of these things we worry about so I
think one you know digital optimist
shouldn't be naive to digital
implementation because if there's one
thing that
slow the benefits of digital it is the
adoption and again I'll pick on your
background because you know it very well
right you know the design and build
infrastructure business runs with a
certain cadence and a certain dynamic we
touched on before this about you know if
people someone's building this and and
you guys say okay I need a hundred
lights in this in this light bulb
there's pressure on that building
project to do it at the most cost
effective area so if you're not careful
the value of connected lighting suddenly
goes out the window we always we are we
also talked about a little bit of the
challenges of some of these low cost
imports coming in and are they really
delivering the value that people think
you know as consumers we're very price
conscious you know you could argue
that's what made Walmart so successful
right the best product the right place
for the right location but you've got to
be careful is the value really in that
you know my father-in-law before I even
joined philips Lighting offered to
upgrade my lighting system at my home
and in my landscaping and I was thrilled
god bless him he got online he did all
this research all these boxes started
showing up did the whole thing less than
a year later fifty percent of those
lights don't work yeah so thinking
through that whole value proposition so
so the implementation side and really
understanding the value and therefore
the idea of collaborating across silos
is something that should not be
underestimated that is easier said than
done
absolutely so we now have time for
questions from the audience and I know
that you can text them in the
instructions are on your tabletop so you
open up a website and then you just ask
your questions and Anna you've been
monitoring those questions what do you
wanna throw our way okay great you know
and I apologize in advance we're not
gonna be able to get to all of them but
wanted to let you knew that so a
question about privacy so does the idea
of connectivity also push the idea of
increased protection of privacy and how
our innovative companies like Philips
thinking about this issue a very
excellent topic and fairly topical in
the news this week with mr. Zuckerberg
and what Facebook at doing and it's
interesting I had a whiteboard session
with the the mayor of San Juan this
morning and she just passionately was
growing up what she needs from a new
infrastructure and two parts of the
conversation which I thought was
fascinating was one how do we make it
all digital but then the immediate
follow-on question needs to be how do
you make it securely digital and if
we're not careful we are putting digital
solutions all over the place and
security is a little bit of an
afterthought and we don't really stress
test the security of those so one it's a
security as a fundamental and to
candidly I think digital optimists
shouldn't get carried away to themselves
they've got to understand the community
that they are there talking to and
addressing and you know privacy security
concerns if they're real issues but I
think we've got to correct the right
right balance you know the analogy I
always use is you know people used to
walk in front of the automobile with a
flag slowing it down as well right we
eventually got comfortable the
automobile and decided to put speed
limits on freeways so there's this sort
of an adoption process we need to think
through I know you got a lot of
questions I'll try to make the answers
quicker so I know that you and the mayor
of San Juan talked about life I which
shows a lot of promise
so does Phillips have plans to work with
the device market laptops and phones to
integrate Wi-Fi hardware in their
products I think the quick answer is yes
and obviously we're excited about the
future opportunity we also feel you've
got to be careful with some of these new
technologies they're not a panacea to
every connectivity issue what you're
seeing now with life.i with
next-generation Wi-Fi narrowband IOT you
know bluetooth ZigBee there's multiple
connectivity options now so you've got
to just think through where is that best
suited to the best use case next
question can you talk about energy for
enabling the computing this person is
worried that all of the energy gains
that we've gotten from switching to LEDs
would get lost in the in the race to
remain connected that's a that's an
excellent question and I think this is
where the the not just the design
community but the user community the
people that operate these things need to
be thinking it through however even with
LED technology we haven't really
implemented a tremendous amount of
sensor technology so you know even LEDs
can
get left on and so I think the
combination of a correctly architectured
digital environment with the remote
amount of sensors can hopefully stay
ahead of that curve right so next
question as the developing world grows
what are the challenges Phillip sees in
the future of the lighting industry boy
that's a good one
challenges in the lighting industry and
specifically one lighting like many
industries always has a pressure of
commoditization and I touched on it
earlier right you know the the the the
the low pressure point of cost you've
got to think through not cost about
value so on the one hand we are
committed to the lamp business the LED
business we're gonna be in the lighting
business for a long time but we also
recognize in fact we made an
announcement just to two weeks ago that
our entire product line will be either
connected or connectable within the next
three to five years so we believe the
connected side is going to help us with
the commodity side because of all the
benefits we've talked about you
mentioned that you are devoting five
percent towards R&D so how much of a
commitment do you have with venture
funding we don't actually publicly
announce that and actually the good news
is it's a growing number and as a public
company I think where we're noticing and
conferences like this a great examples
of realizing that startup community can
help us move faster and cover more bases
so now we've got an act an active our
acquisition strategy partnership
strategy
I mentioned American towers we actually
have a partnership with my old company
Cisco we're gonna be announcing a number
of other companies so you touched on
this ecosystem play I think the good
news is Philips is pretty grounded in
realizing we're gonna do lighting and
connected lighting very well but it is
going to take a proverbial village to to
deliver all these all these benefits so
related to that what would you like to
see as signifies unique innovation 50
years from now Oh
you know it's a great question it's a
great thought-provoking question you
know when people ask me questions like
that I actually have a sort of an
immediate pragmatic swing back to if we
could do if we could just deliver what
we're all talking about that makes this
world incredibly safe incredibly
connected you know hopefully you know we
can feed everyone we can educate
everyone and so I don't think there's
any magic bullet behind that I think if
we can just roll our sleeves up and get
get on and do some of the stuff that's
already done
we could see fantastic you know we don't
have to wait 50 years for the benefit we
can get on with it
so are you seeing an impact between
light frequencies and health and
motivational feeling so the quick answer
is yes and I touched on it before there
is definitely it depends what the
question is so light frequencies and the
impact of light obviously how you use
light right if we build this light down
off the lunch it's probably not the best
strategy from a meeting perspective so
trying to increase the light gradually
that doesn't scare us either so there's
there's definitely and we're trying to
figure out again how we work with the
design community the operating community
to to make that a reality you can do it
today but we're not we don't have the
Opera House you know how many people
have been in a meeting room with this
beautiful there's one right over there
right gorgeous control panel on the wall
to do all these cool things and it
reminds me back and I'll share my ate
you know show my age here a little bit
it's good it's good old VCR days right
you know there's a VCR sitting on your
TV and that the lights flashing because
no one knows how to program the the damn
little clock you know as I guarantee
there's probably more power in that
panel than in the space shuttle in
Apollo 13 but can someone come in and
help us use a tech thing right so we've
got to make it I give Apple a lot of
credits right a lot and big fan of
apples you know no user manual an app
that makes it work hopefully we can
adopt it and use the benefits more you
know maybe I can just ask a question
that I've had is with that is what what
concerns do you have about the Sun
setting of operating systems
and being able to if I switch my phone
if I switch my software and I've got all
my hardware connected to that how do you
future-proof against that I you know
it's a great question I'm not sure I
have the right answer and I you know I
hope especially my old tech industry
gets better better and better at that
because on the one hand it's easy for
tech companies to go do it in fact
there's a great one line it's like why
was a why was God have it to build the
world in seven days because there was no
infrastructure to upgrade you know and
it was you know and I think companies
kind of cheat a little bit say I'll
forget that infrastructure don't go with
them go with a new one yeah so I know
we're getting a hook a little bit you
have one last question just one last
question is that from you though we have
students in the room so give us a couple
of last thoughts for our students your
future employees tell us what you'd like
for us to know yeah come join us in help
I think is the quickest reminder it's
that but in all seriousness no it's a
you know we we need we need bright smart
minds I just had a meeting down in
Argentina with some of our early and
career people and my goodness the
passion the energy the the openness to
adopting future things versus candidly a
lot of you know companies are like well
we couldn't do that you know we haven't
done that 400 yeah we've done this the
same way for a hundred years so one I
think it's that to think about the
application of whatever you're studying
and doing into whatever you're
passionate about the private sector the
public sector philanthropic areas you
know whether you're into engineering
computer science you know humanities
think about all the good stuff you learn
how can you take that out and make an
impact and don't let the company
including a Philips suck that out of you
and try and make you conform to the good
old ways that it got done we need bright
motivated people to help change the
world and adopt this technology faster
than we do it the normal way great thank
you very much
[Applause]
thank you Chris I know that that we were
so excited that you were able to join us
you're so new in your position and we
have a lot of lighting enthusiasts in
the in the room who were so glad to see
you here so thank you a bit of
housekeeping for those of you who are
still in the room we're about to start
parts of our Allegheny clean tech
University prize competition but I do
want to let you know that at 1:30 we
have some tours that are happening so if
you are scheduled for a tour the tours
will be meeting at the registration desk
at 1:30 but you there are quite a few
things that are happening between now
and then but I just wanted to make sure
that everyone knew 1:30 the field trips
will also meet outside to be walked over
to the shuttle they're meeting at the
shuttle so if you are going on in one of
the field trips that's in a shuttle it
will be outside but again this isn't an
hour at 1:30 thank you which is back so
with that I'd like to introduce J
Whittaker dr. J Whittaker is the
director of the Scott Institute for
energy innovation who's going to be
making our introduce introductions for
the afternoon
welcome this is kind of a transition for
energy week we're now moving into the
the most excellent competition that is
hopefully going to crown by the end of
the day a big winner and it's a fairly
intensive process that will last the
next five or six hours and we're super
excited to kick it off we have a very
special guest here today who will be
overseeing part and parcel of the of
this competition her name is chanel
Armstrong she's a registered patent
attorney and as a director of department
of energy's technology transitions
office
Armstrong coordinates technology
transition efforts across department
backed efforts national laboratories
research facilities and program offices
as well as oversees the energy investor
center and technology commercialization
fund she also advises energy secretary
Rick Perry on technology transfer and
commercialization matters
Armstrong holds a bachelor's degree in
electrical engineering from Carnegie
Mellon University yay and an MBA from
Long Island University in a JD from
Rutgers without further ado I'd like to
welcome Jeannette who's gonna give us
some comments and we will start this
process thank you for coming
[Applause]
well welcome to the clean tech
university a prize competition for the
Allegheny region it's sponsored by US
Department of Energy and this
competition is actually one of eight
regional competitions nationwide that
will provide $50,000 prize I'm happy to
be here as jr. announced I am currently
director of the office of tech
transitions at Department of Energy and
before I start I thought I'll give you a
very quick snapshot of what do he does
and what office of tech transition does
at the goe do he conducts basic research
and a PI research in diverse fields very
diverse fields from nuclear physics to
environmental science to batteries
nuclear weapons renewable energy super
competing for example and goe conducts
these these research through a network
of 17 National Labs you might recognize
some of the names for example Sandia
Laura's little more those Alamos are
gone for example so do invest very
heavily in our D basic and Applied as I
mentioned before and do a research
accounts for 40% of do a expenditures
which which is over 30 billion dollars
per year so within the OEE I head up the
office office of technology transitions
which is ot typical OTT it's a
relatively new office it was established
in 2015
and we oversee and expand commercial
impact of the investment that we make in
NRD at do e so our goal is to improve
and maximize accessibility of the
national labs to to increase the
partnership between the industry and
what's going on at the laboratories our
office responsibly extends over do a
program 17 laboratories and other
research and facilities that's located
throughout the country so overview of
the competition teams there are 44
states represented here today
Pennsylvania Ohio West Virginia and
Maryland a top teams from this regional
competition will go to the national
competition and have an opportunity with
even more prizes not only from the power
of energy but Department of Defense as
well winning teams will also receive
additional business development and
commercialization training and other
education opportunities this may sound
may not sound very important but we have
found that the commercialization
training is actually very important as
part of our R&D because you can have the
greatest innovation but if you cannot
market in and commercialize and put it
in a format that's that's accessible and
interesting to the marketplace you
cannot promote your amazing innovation
so the details of the competition there
are three parts first part which will
begin shortly is a one-minute elevator
pitches these pitches with along with
there will be a poster sessions starting
at 3:45 in the Danforth room we
we'll be selected as fan-favorite so in
addition to three finalists there will
be another winner selected called fan
favorite
so audience can participate in selecting
these another team four from the judging
process this is a link which can type
into any electronic device that you will
have access to the forum to pick your
pick your team that you like best and
then the top three teams will make their
ten minute pitches finals back in this
room at 5:00 p.m. so with that I like to
invite our first team to come up and
make their long one minute speech
yeah
I feel like I should have had a routine
for this how's everyone doing today
yes
okay okay
[Music]
did you vote for eka Church okay I've
been fascinated by a renewable energy
ever since I lived in the highlands of
Guatemala when I came back to the United
States I had the opportunity to visit a
wind farm and was kind of struck by the
sheer size of the blades I mean one
blade spans the length of an entire
football field and I was wondering how
do these guys these operators know when
a blade is wearing down or when it's
sustained damage and I was surprised to
find out that a couple of times a year
they'll send people up into the turbines
and they have to rappel down the blade
and physically monitor the wind turbine
blade to check for damage and I thought
there's got to be a better way in this
day and age now remote sensing allows
engineers safely on the ground to
collect data multiple times a day an
active charge our technology takes that
one step further by removing the need
for batteries so that you can install
the sensor inside of the turbine and
collect data without any shutdowns of
the turbine generation thank you
[Applause]
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen my
name is Prince Ghosh and I'm the founder
and CEO of banner labs we're a startup
spun out of research conducted at Case
Western Reserve University in Cleveland
Ohio focused on commercializing our
dielectric barrier discharge plasma
actuator technology essentially what
we've created is a thin flexible
solid-state electrode that can be
applied in the form of a tape right to
the surface of a wind turbine blade when
activated our electrodes generate a thin
layer of non thermal plasma over the
surface of the blade and control the air
flowing around it with the series of
electric fields
this yields an increase in aerodynamic
efficiency and overall power output of
the turbine by about 4 percent we've
tested benchtop scale tests at Case
Western Reserve and are partnered with
NASA Glenn Research Center in Cleveland
Ohio to conduct full-scale wind tunnel
testing I have a vision that one day
every turbine in America is going to
have our technology on it pushing us one
step closer to offsetting the effects of
fossil fuels thank you so much for your
time
[Applause]
good afternoon i'm nathaniel mclean from
Coppin State University have you ever
been caught at 3% in today's day and age
we have a constant need to charge our
portable devices but the problem is all
these solutions are either bulky
expensive our environmentally unfriendly
our Coppin State University
we sold a steady solar tech team is
using technology that can be integrated
into backpacks using natural days to
generate power from sunlight we're
currently working with touring companies
to get the technology into your backpack
so that you can charge on the go we're
hoping to reach out to the some 3,000
students at Coppin State University and
expand to about 400,000 students in
Maryland to given them the power to
charge on-the-go giving you an
affordable efficient energy friendly
environmentally friendly option that you
can use on the go and stay in fashion
thank you very much
Coppin State University
[Applause]
what if I told you that this Apple had
the potential to be so much more than
just trash what if I told you that we
had a system that could help solve this
160 billion dollar food waste problem
our sivir system is the first of its
kind that is easily deployable and can
help restaurants profit off of two
different types of revenue streams the
first is the clean energy that we can
produce from the third their food waste
and the second is the fertilizer that we
can give back to the communities we have
already raised over $100,000 within one
year and have created Pittsburgh's first
portable farming system additionally we
are launching our first prototype of our
anaerobic digestion system in May and
have been receiving interest from
companies internationally we're ecotone
renewables we are here to close the food
loop and we are creating a 21st century
food system thank you to put yourself in
the shoes of a scientist who's working
at Philips
whose job is to design diets when you're
designing these lights there are
multiple design choices you can
conditions you want to put them in and
if I chose how do you separate out of it
today that disorder of the case
unfortunately the way many companies
design lights or batteries or any other
products is actually a very painful
process they get word of a scientist ask
them to analyze spreadsheets and
switching some data to come up with a
new design mess it up and keep utilizing
this for possibly hundreds of iterations
until they find something that satisfies
their needs and this is the
high-pressure situation to be in
especially if you know that fast
innovation and discovery is what defines
a success and here's where becoming at
experiment their group of machine
learning experts who have developed many
high platform we can choose better
experiments to suit your needs and make
this parallel process more efficient and
well traditionally people can't use
software as a service or platforms a
service as a business business model for
services like this our goal is to
develop a platform to develop patent and
[Applause]
hi we are grid fruit from Carnegie
Mellon in the US there are more than
200,000 grocery stores and they operate
on razor thin profit margins around one
percent that means today they're
suffering as Amazon takes more and more
market share the supermarket's
refrigerators alone take up to 20
percent of their potential profits these
refrigerators are gathering data from
different components but that data stays
separate and never sees the light of day
at grid fruit we have an AI platform
that takes this data collects it and
applies Rai learning algorithms to
provide the customers with optimal
temperature set points and customize
tailored maintenance recommendations to
reduce their costs by up to 15%
now these customers are generating over
a trillion dollars in revenue every year
and our market is eight billion dollars
per year we have one pilot going to in
the works we're bringing AI to your
grocery store thank you imagine you're
driving your shiny new electric vehicle
cruising across Allegheny County but
then when you see those red flashing
danger lights flashing across your
dashboard no battery understandably
you'll be anxious you want to find the
next available charging station but
they're just not enough not one that's
certainly available to your vehicle's
remaining range what do you do this is
where we bridge the gap hi my name is
Ashwin and I'm from electricity with
Carnegie Mellon University we work with
residential small commercial locations
and electric vehicle drivers in
providing affordable fast charging
equipment that is compatible with any
electric vehicle in today's market we
are assuring economy business model that
enables host:2 to basically share their
charges for any other electric vehicle
to come and charge we are electricity
and we make sure that your electric
vehicle travel is a lot less anxious
thank you
[Applause]
good afternoon good afternoon there we
go okay so my name is David Smith and
I'm here representing Western University
and square line power score line powers
and mission has brought safe durable
solutions to the modern electrical
problems we have this day using that
doing inductive charging power using
wireless power in our first application
we look to target the 30,000 new
internet cafes I have been open the last
15 years with that using furniture to
charge the laptops and cell phones that
you all use in I use while I sit there
and not buy anything into coffee shops
to make it so that every 30 minutes you
charge per 50 cents or $1 or something
like that to be able to make they have
recurring cash flows whenever it comes
to the business second phase is to move
on to drone charging so thank you the
law enforcement can make it so that the
cutoff for the unplugging of the drones
end up so that they save countless time
for emergencies thank you very much
[Applause]
poop is a serious problem and it's an
especially big problem when it comes to
water conservation energy and health the
standard toilet uses six liters per
flush and when that scales up that means
that we're flushing away 100 billion
litres of water every day reducing the
toilets water footprint would lead to
lower energy bills lower water bills and
less wasted water but conventional
toilet surfaces need water to prevent
fouling and foul odors and bacteria
accumulation so to address to lower the
water footprint of a toilet while also
maintaining a clean toilet experience
we've developed a sprayable surface
coating that can repel liquids solid
waste and also bacteria any residue left
behind on our surface can be washed away
with 90 percent less water than a
conventional toilet surface our ultimate
goal is to revolutionize the way that
waste is managed and perhaps with the
coating like ours
one day toilets will be able to keep
themselves clean while also reducing
their environmental impact thank you
[Applause]
conventional energy sources are dying
causes and have left in their wake
pressing environmental health issues and
expensive removals of hazardous wastes
to combat these we propose the
advancement of a new sector of renewable
energy plant generated electricity we
give you then charge an idea that
employs the multi-faceted applications
of the generation of electricity through
plants with carbon electrodes and a
power harvester attached to a
constructed array of plants we can now
use the very nature we are trying to
preserve to supplement our electricity
needs 24/7 in particular our latest
innovative focus atom charge involves an
electricity producing green wall the
utilization of revolutionary all
inclusive technology safeguarding our
power and our earth this is n charge
thank you hello my name is Tim I am from
HEC green hawks compact composter the
problem that we have today is many
residential areas proofs about six about
four pounds of compostable waste each
day but most residential areas do not
have composters that can meet their
demands especially ones that are
automatic they're not there
our goal at HCC green Hawks is to create
a composter that can man cadet can
automatically biodegrade the matter
quicker and faster without the need for
manual labor of having to continuously
turn it and add water this will
automatically do all this for you thank
you
[Applause]
thank you all the team members thank you
for coming up just figuring out what you
have to say in one minute that's that's
really difficult so now audience please
remember to vote for your favorite team
so they can another team can have an
award also at 3:45 is when the poster
session is please this is way too short
for you to figure out learn more about
what's going on with its great great
innovation have been discussed here
please start by at 3:45 Danford room
which is just past the festive place
that are on this floor to talk to the
team members and and ask about the
innovations and please return here at 5
o'clock to see who won the $50,000 award
thank you Harris
[Applause]